[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis ein schönen guten abend
wünsche ich ihnen herzlich willkommen
und mein leben und der hat heute
wirklich viel fußball für sie und ihre
mutter vom und wir beginnen die sendung
mit einem versprechen des kanzlers you
never walk alone
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
zeiten bewältigen das sei entscheidend
sagt kanzler scholz und kündigt wegen
der hohen energiepreise weitere
entlastungen an
wieder freie fahrt für frachter die
ukraine und russland öffnen einen
korridor am schwarzen meer millionen
tonnen getreide könnten bald in alle
welt verschifft werden
und ein hart erkämpfter sieg nach dem 2
2 gegen österreich stehen die deutschen
frauen im halbfinale der em
der kanzler kündigt heute beides in
einem atemzug an die bundesregierung
will mit mehreren milliarden euro den
gasversorger juniper retten darauf
schauen wir gleich und die menschen
sollen finanziell stärker entlastet
werden zb durch eine reform des
wohngeldes und das geplante bürgergeld
die einzelheiten von britta spiekermann
olaf scholz heute überraschend aus dem
urlaub zurück durchaus ungewöhnlich die
energie krise zwingt zur weiteren
schnell handeln 30 milliarden entlastung
pakete sind schon auf dem weg jetzt soll
weitere hilfe für die bevölkerung kommen
in jedem seiner sätze schwingt mit die
lage ist ernst scholz gibt ein
versprechen
you never walk alone
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten dass es entscheidend
niemand wird mit seinen
herausforderungen und problemen alleine
gelassen nahezu paradox das
milliardenschwere rettungspaket für
juniper bedeutet weitere
preissteigerungen denn der
energiekonzern kann jetzt höhere
einkaufspreise an die kunden weitergeben
je nachdem wie groß der haushalt ist
wird das durchaus auch spürbar werden
dann für die einzelnen haushalte wenn es
um bürgern und bürger gibt das kann
schon sein dass damit noch mal
zusätzliche belastungen verbunden sind
die 200 oder 300 euro für eine
vierköpfige familie im betragen können
scholz flankiert diese hiobsbotschaft
weitere preissteigerung mit neuen
entlastungen mehr menschen sollen
künftig wohngeld beziehen können
heizkostenzuschüsse dauerhaft gezahlt
werden geplant ist auch rechtlicher
schutz für menschen die miet und
nebenkosten nicht mehr aufbringen können
vieles ist geplant details noch unklar
das bürgergeld somit höheren sätzen
schon zum ersten 120 123 in kraft treten
noch aber verhandelt die ampel über den
nachfolger von hartz iv die regierung
will unsicherer zeiten weiter absichern
das ausmaß ist kaum abzuschätzen denn es
bleibt diese große unbekannte was ihnen
keiner hier seriös sagen können es wie
sich die preise für energie auf den
weltmärkten entwickeln werden
trotzdem man werde als land stabil durch
diese herausforderungen kommen sagt
scholz noch und geht vorrangig sei der
schutz der bevölkerung in einer nie
gekannten krise
bald also dürfen die energiekonzerne wie
juniper die höheren preise an industrie
und stadtwerke weitergeben und damit an
alle verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
juni stand vor der pleite da nicht genug
gas aus russland kommt muss das
unternehmen kurzfristig welches am markt
einkaufen und das kostet deutlich mehr
jetzt wird die bundesregierung mit 30
prozent bei juniper einsteigen mehr dazu
von ralph goldmann
erst vor zwei wochen rief deutschlands
größter gasversorger erstmals nach
staatlicher hilfe der erste kredit in
höhe von zwei milliarden euro war schon
nach einer woche aufgebraucht jetzt
spannend der bund einen größeren
rettungsschirm der vorstandschef ist
erleichtert man will als unternehmen
nicht in diese situation kommen beim
start anzuklopfen wir reden am ende des
tages über das geld der steuerzahler
hier kommt geld der steuerzahler zu
hilfe einem unternehmen konkret kauft
der bund neue aktien im wert von 267
millionen euro
die regierung verpflichtet sich bei
bedarf bis zu 7,7 milliarden euro zur
verfügung zu stellen der bestehende
kredit wird von zwei auf neun milliarden
euro erhöht
natürlich hoffen glauben wir dass mit
den maßnahmen die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben das unternehmen so
stabilisiert ist
das ist auch seine verpflichtungen aus
diesen verträgen früher oder später zu
erfüllen kann dass das für die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler auch
gut ausgeht juniper beliefert die
großindustrie und rund 100 stadtwerke
mit gas und gilt als systemrelevant eine
pleite wäre möglicherweise noch viel
teurer geworden glaubt der energie
experte heiko lohmann insofern ist ein
guter dinge gewesen weil jetzt einfach
zu einer stabilisierung der situation
beiträgt und das wäre schon für den
markt insgesamt ein riesenproblem wenn
man juniper wenn juniper jetzt im guten
insolvenz gegangen
möglicherweise könnten nach juniper
weitere unternehmen in schieflage
geraten der bundeskanzler betonte heute
notfalls werde man auch andere
energieversorger retten
das kommt nicht so oft vor dass ein
kanzler für eine pressekonferenz seinen
urlaub unter bericht stark unter labadee
scholz wollte also offensichtlich nicht
länger warten mit dem versprechen
niemand werde alleingelassen kann also
die menschen beruhigen also er versucht
es zumindest und zwar mit einem sehr
starken signal das so in der politik nur
ziemlich selten vorkommt mit einer
umfassenden garantie angela merkel hat
das mit ihrem finanzminister steinbrück
schon einmal gemacht in der finanzkrise
als sie die spareinlagen der deutschen
für garantiert erklärt hat mario draghi
der ezb-chef hat 2012 das mal gemacht
als es um die rettung des euro ging und
jetzt eben olaf scholz mit seinem großen
versprechen dass niemand weder
wirtschaft noch privatpersonen allein
gelassen werden mit steigenden
energiepreisen
wie lange dieses versprechen halten muss
wie teuer das ganze wird und woher das
geld dann kommt und wofür die
bundesregierung dann an anderer stelle
vielleicht sparen muss oder doch noch
mal über die schuldenbremse reden müsste
das kann jetzt noch niemand absehen aber
auf jeden fall ist das versprechen jetzt
einmal da und es wäre nicht das erste
mal dass es zumindest die gemüter
vorübergehend beruhigt danke für diese
einschätzung container bennati
gute nachrichten aus der ukraine gab es
zuletzt kaum noch jetzt aber denn schon
bald könnte das vom krieg gebeutelte
land wieder getreide exportieren heute
wurde eine einigung unterzeichnet
die blockade durch russland hatte vor
allem arme länder in afrika hart
getroffen denn viele beziehen fast ihren
gesamten bedarf aus der region ums
schwarze meer hungersnöte wurden
befürchtet der weizenpreis schoss
zeitweise wie sie sehen können um fast
40 prozent in die höhe über die heutige
einigung berichtet glück wird
das tiefe misstrauen ist auch nach vier
monaten verhandlungen deutlich spürbar
russlands verteidigungsminister schoigu
unterschreibt als erster heute das
abkommen in istanbul dann der
ukrainische infrastrukturminister cobra
kof gemeinsam wollten sie nicht an den
tisch dennoch spricht un-generalsekretär
guterres von einem hoffnungsschimmer
das ist ein gutes abkommen für die ganze
welt es wird entwicklungsländern am
rande des zusammenbruchs und durch
hungersnot am meisten gefährdeten
menschen erleichterung bringen
mehrere millionen tonnen getreide warten
in der ukraine auf den export weil
seeminen und die russische kriegsmarine
die schifffahrt unmöglich machen das
abkommen soll jetzt eine sichere passage
für getreide schiffe aus drei
hafenanlagen im raum odessa garantieren
durch das schwarze meer und den bosporus
zu den bestimmungshafen in aller welt
seeminen sollen bei bedarf an einem
drittland entschärft werden russland
garantiert dass die getreide schiffe
nicht angegriffen werden die exporte und
kontrollaufgaben werden von einer
leitstelle der un in istanbul genehmigt
und überwacht für den türkischen
präsidenten erdogan der die
vermittlerrolle übernommen hatte ein
großer diplomatischer erfolg
ich hoffe dass dieser gemeinsame schritt
den wir heute zusammen mit der ukraine
und russland unternommen haben ein
wendepunkt sein kann und die hoffnungen
auf frieden neu belegt
die ukraine hofft auf eine schnelle
umsetzung der vereinbarung denn auf den
feldern wartet schon die neue ernte auf
abnehmer
in russland und der ukraine sind für uns
für bäcker und dara hassanzadeh und wir
beginnen mit dem blicken in die ukraine
zu ihm nach odessa daran die ukraine
hatte ja lange eine entfernung termin
abgelehnt aus sorge vor russischen
angriffen wie reagieren die menschen
denn jetzt auf diese einigung auf diese
nachricht
ja die minen vor dem hafen von odessa im
meer die hatten ja den sinn die stadt zu
schützen vor russischen landung truppen
seit dem abschuss und im untergang der
moskwa und auch zeit der eroberung von
der schlangen insel ist diese bedrohung
einfach viel geringer geworden was
allerdings groß ist der druck im hafen
die silos sind voll wir sind seit
gestern 800 kilometer durchs land
gefahren ganz im norden von kratos
runter nach odessa und überall saßen die
bauern auf ihren mähdreschern nun haben
die ernte eingeholt und die müssen
natürlich jetzt silos haben wo sie die
unterbringen können so ist es ein großer
tag für die ukraine die ukraine sind
sehr verbunden mit ihrem land fiel auch
die städter haben datschen bauen gerne
an und das wird auch moralisch dem land
und den menschen gibt es hier auftritt
das kann man schon so sagen also
positive reaktion der ukraine gehen wir
noch weiter nach russland nach moskau zu
ihnen filme die russische führung hat
sich ja erst gegen eine einigung
gesperrt wie erklärt sich denn da dieser
sinneswandel
für die russische seite war immer
wichtig dass nicht nur über den
ukrainischen weizen verhandelt wird
sondern auch über die ausfuhr von
russischem getreide und russischen
düngemitteln die sind zwar selbst nicht
von sanktionen betroffen aber eben der
transport der die versicherung und die
finanzierung die sind durch die
strafmaßnahmen schwieriger geworden und
das schmerzt moskau denn allein durch
düngemittel hat es im letzten jahr 12 5
milliarden dollar eingenommen nach
darstellung der russischen seite wurde
heute in istanbul auch ein memorandum
unterzeichnet dass russland die
unterstützung der vereinten nationen zu
sichern bei der erleichterung von export
seiner agrarprodukte und das würde dann
bedeuten dass russland jetzt also
erstmal sein vermeintlich humanitäres
gesicht zeigen kann indem es sich an der
lösung der drohenden welthunger krise
beteiligt hat die es ja nebenbei gesagt
selbst ausgelöst hatte und ganz nebenher
im windschatten sozusagen noch
sicherstellt dass es wieder selbst mit
verdienen kann
dankeschön für begaben und gras unter
dem
was bedeutet die heutige einigung zb für
die getreidepreise das und mehr
beantworten während der zdf- heute- app
dort haben wir die wichtigsten fragen
und antworten für sie zusammengestellt
im streit über wechselt regeln für die
britische provinz nordirland hat die eu
kommission vier neue verfahren gegen die
regierung in london eingeleitet brüssel
wirft großbritannien vor gegen
wesentliche teile des sogenannten noland
protokolls zu verstoßen dabei geht es um
zollvorschriften und die kontrolle von
waren jetzt droht ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof
mehr als drei stunden
genauer gesagt
187 minuten lang hat der ehemalige
us-präsident trump untätig zugeschaut
wie seine anhänger und anhängerinnen mit
gewalt ins kapitol eindrang so die
rekonstruktion des
untersuchungsausschusses des us
repräsentantenhauses zum sechsten januar
20 21 trump hat demnach bewusste gewalt
in kauf genommen um an der macht zu
bleiben jetzt fand dazu die vorläufig
letzte öffentliche anhörung statt
nie zuvor gezeigte video die vor
aufzeichnung von kramp rede am tag nach
dem angriff aufs kapital er will nicht
sagen die wahl ist vorüber
der ausschuss zeigt was im weißen haus
passierte während des umsturzversuchs
trump schaute im esszimmer stundenlang
fox news und tat nichts um den aufstand
zu beenden
also mein ausgedrückt habe ich ihm
gesagt es muss ein öffentliches
statement geben schnellstens dass die
leute das capitol verlassen müssen
stattdessen hat trump die gewalttätige
stimmung gegen seinen vize mike pence
mit einem tweet weiter angeheizt weil
der seinen plan nicht unterstützte und
trump wisse genau um die wirkung seiner
worte
sie klammern sich wirklich an jedes wort
das er sagt jeden tweet in diesem moment
der tweet gegen mike pence das war öl
ins feuer
die untersuchungen sollen zeigen dass
trump absichtlich nichts unternahm er
seine anhänger genau das taten was er
wollte es gibt hier juristen die ganz
klar von fahrrad sprechen ob es aber am
ende handfeste beweise für eine
vorsätzliche straftat gibt es noch
umstritten die entscheidung über eine
mögliche anklage trifft der
justizminister die ausschussmitglieder
jedenfalls sind von krems schuld
überzeugt
es ist ein schandfleck auf unserer
geschichte und eine entero aller die für
unsere demokratie ihr leben geopfert
haben
der ausschuss will erreichen dass trump
nie wieder präsident wird
zurück nach deutschland
volkswagen tauscht überraschend sein
vorstandschef aus aber dies gehe zum
ersten september teilte der wolfsburger
autobauer vor einer stunde mend der 63
jährige führt den konzern seit 2008 10
sein nachfolger soll der chef der
sportwagentochter porsche ag oliver
blume werben frage nach unserem
korrespondenten in niedersachsen peter
kunst warum muss dies gehen er ist dann
reizfigur und er hat es am schluss
einfach überreizt herbert diess hatte
sich nachdem diese skandal die spitze
beim größten deutschen arbeitgeber
erobert aber er ist er einsam geblieben
seine ideen beim umbau zur
elektromobilität zum beispiel das hatte
schon visionären charakter aber er hat
es auch immer wieder geschafft alle
gegen sich aufzubringen den betriebsrat
den aufsichtsrat den er regelrecht
beleidigt hat das land niedersachsen als
anteilseigner
den ganzen konzern wenn er zum beispiel
den abbau form zigtausend arbeitsplätzen
ins spiel brachte ohne dass mit jemandem
abgesprochen zu haben kurz
zusammengefasst er ist kein teamplayer
und das braucht ein großer konzern wie
volkswagen dann offensichtlich doch
zuletzt war es eigentlich nur noch die
familien porsche und piëch die größten
anteilseigner bei volkswagen die ihm
immer die stange hielten aus
profitinteresse aber zuletzt jetzt
strauchelt der konzern auch beim umbau
beim ausbau zu einem software zu einer
softwareplattform für den ganzen konzern
und das ist der moment wo dann sozusagen
auch von diesen familien die reißleine
gerissen wurde nun muss er gehen eine
ahnung von peter kunz 4 lang
16 richterinnen und richter zählt das
höchste deutsche gericht das
bundesverfassungsgericht und einer ist
jetzt neu dabei heinrich amadeus wolff
jurist und professor an der uni bayreuth
der 56 jährige wurde in karlsruhe ins
amt eingeführt und soll sich unter
anderem um fälle im sozial- und kunst
recht kümmern der bundestag hatte ihn
als nachfolger für den richter andreas
paulus gewählt dessen amtszeit nach
zwölf jahren abgelaufen ist
deutlich hat sich der vatikan ja gegen
den synodalen weg der katholischen
kirche in deutschland gestellt und davor
gewarnt eigenmächtig reformen
durchzusetzen
katholische laien und bischöfe reagieren
darauf jetzt mit kritik dringen auf ein
gespräch mit dem heiligen stuhl beim
synodalen weg beraten sie unter anderem
über die öffnung kirchliche ämter für
frauen
auslöser waren die vielen fälle
sexualisierter gewalt in der kirche
michael flood bioland über den konflikt
eine offizielle erklärung aus rom völlig
unklar von wem es gibt keine
unterschrift
es liest sich wie eine warnung an
deutsche katholiken keinen sonderweg
keine eigenmächtigen reformen der
synodale weg in deutschland ist nicht
befugt die bischöfe und die gläubigen
zur annahme neuer formen der leitung und
neuer ausrichtungen der lehre und der
moral zu verpflichten heißt es aus rom
es gibt streit um die zukunft der
katholischen kirche dabei betonen
reformer dass es hauptsächlich um
vorschläge geht
da liebig wird ja keine festlegung
machen sondern lokale wegberg
lösungsvorschläge machen und das jetzt
rom jetzt sind gerade in dieser
sommerzeit jetzt sich die augen und
ohren zuhält und nicht mal die richtigen
fragen gestellt haben will das macht
mich doch sehr stutzig die richtigen
fragen sie drehen sich aus sicht des
modalen weges um macht die rolle der
frauen und sexualmoral aber die
kommunikation nach rom scheint gestört
es zeugt von keinem guten stil der
kommunikation innerhalb der kirche wenn
nicht namentlich gezeichnete erklärungen
veröffentlicht werden heißt es aus
deutschland
unklar bleibt welche konsequenzen das
schreiben haben wird ich glaube die
hoffnung in diesem dokument ist dass
dann die stimme der deutschen kirche
eine minderheitenmeinung ist aber ich
glaube diese hoffnung wird nicht
aufgehen denn auch in anderen ländern
werden stimmen lauter kirche
zukunftsfähiger zu machen auch um
kirchenbänke wieder zu füllen
beides auf dem rasen bodenständig und
bescheiden im herzen nach dem tod von
uwe seeler gestern ist die trauer in
seiner hamburger heimat besonders groß
am uwe seeler denkmal beim hsv stadion
legten fans zum abschied zahlreiche
blumen und schals nieder stellten kerzen
auf die stadt hat trauerbeflaggung
angeordnet und legt am mittag ein
kondolenzbuch für ihren gestorbenen
ehrenbürger aus bis auf weiteres können
die menschen dort ihr beileid ausdrücken
und von der fußball-legende uwe seeler
jetzt zu den deutschen fußball frauen
und ihrer mission ja gestern am nicht so
souverän wie in der vorrunde aber
gewonnen ist gewonnen 2 zu 0 stand es am
ende des viertelfinals gegen starke
österreicherinnen die gerade in der
ersten halbzeit das dfb team ganz schön
unter druck setzen so analysiert das
auch svenja huth gelöst und glücklich
über den sieg vor 4 stunden den west
london auf dem termin mit den medien ja
ich glaube dass wir speziell auch in der
ersten halbzeit im spielaufbau nicht so
mutig waren österreich hat uns gerade in
den ersten minuten auch sehr hoch
gepresst und einige gute torchancen
gehabt aber alle ausgelassen drei
aluminiumtreffer für die
österreicherinnen die entsprechend
traurig nach hause fahren aber auch mit
guten wünschen für die siegerinnen
deutschland ist weiter würde sagen dann
bitte
die deutsche presse maschine verleitet
österreich zu fehlern konsequenz sind
zwei tore durch lina magull nach 23
minuten
und durch alexandra popp kurz vor
schluss
ihr vierter treffer im vierten spiel zum
einzug ins halbfinale
fühlt sich gut an aber bin genau wie die
spielerinnen auch auch emotional
natürlich angefasst sehr stolz was wir
heute hier geleistet haben nächsten
mittwoch dann live im zdf übrigens geht
es gegen frankreich oder die niederlande
ja und heute abend entscheidet sich auf
wie in england im halbfinale trifft in
der partie schweden gegen belgien die
skandinavierinnen klarer favorit trotz
krone sorgen vor allem die schwedische
verteidigung ist durch zwei kohona fälle
geschwächt und auch auf kapitänin
caroline seger muss trainer peter
gerhardt sohn möglicherweise verzichten
jeder vierte bereits gegen portugal
wurde da aber perfekt ersetzt von
philippa onkel der zwei tore schoss
onkel beim 15 0 erfolg und den portugal
schwung den wollen die schwedinnen
mitnehmen
wir müssen wieder mit tempo spielen und
auf das setzen was wir gegen portugal
gezeigt haben dann wird es gut wäre
meldet doch die underdogs aus belgien
haben sich hier bislang gut verkauft und
anders als die schwedinnen die gekommen
sind um den titel zu gewinnen haben die
belgierinnen um tine der chemie heute
nichts zu verlieren
19 etappe der tour de france und endlich
darf auch mal la france jubeln dann
christoph laporte der erste etappensieg
der gastgeber weil dieser tour ganz
clever herausgefahren vom franzosen kurz
vor der zielankunft in kauer der
gesamtführende däne jonas windeler
verteidigte sein gelbes trikot der sieg
am sonntag in paris dürfte ihn wohl
nicht mehr zu nehmen sein und dann hätte
nach 26 jahren wieder ein däne die tour
geworden nicht schlecht da
noch kurz das wetter heute nacht gibt es
teils kräftige schauer und gewitter mehr
zugleich von christa orden das
heute-journal können sie an diesem abend
um 22.45 sehen mit wulf schmiese auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend ihn je nachdem
wo sie heute in deutschland waren ergab
sich ein unterschiedlicher tag im norden
hat mir nämlich wolken und auf den
nordfriesischen inseln um die 17 grad im
süden dagegen sonnenschein und hitze bei
33 grad in rheinfelden an der grenze zur
schweiz auch heute nacht ist das ganze
zweigeteilt im norden erreicht wie 11
bis 14 grad im süden milder 15 bis 19
grad und es passieren zwei dinge heute
abend kommen aus dem aus den alpen
heraus kräftige schauer und gewitter auf
lokal auch unwetterartig
starkregen hagel und sturmböen und ab
dem späten abend kommen aus dem
südwesten dann noch einmal neue schauer
und gewitter die sich im nacht verlauf
über die mitte ausbreiten und morgen
vormittag dann im osten an kommen
nachmittags zieht das ganze nach osten
hin raus aber nach einer kurzen
wetterberuhigung mittags entwickeln sich
zwischen dem erzgebirge und dem
alpenrand noch mal neue schauer und
gewitter von westen her da lockert es im
tagesverlauf auf die temperaturen von
nord nach süd meist 20 bis 30 grad am
sonntag beruhigt sich das wetter etwas
die temperaturen nehmen anlauf um am
montag im südosten noch einmal um die 36
grad zu erreichen allerdings kommt dann
aus dem nordwesten eine kaltfront die
das ganze wieder ausräumt